hey guys welcome back to your weekly
desi recap and there wasn't much news
today or pop on reddit announced
yesterday that there wasn't going to be
any decent news to look forward to but
there are a few things I do want to
touch on so let's get started so first
off the new weekly content are the new
executions we've been waiting for since
the beginning of season two if not
earlier most you probably have already
seen them already but if you haven't
seen the video then allow me to show you
enjoy
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
so those are the execution this is
probably the best animations or anything
Ubisoft has ever made and these are
going to be costing you 7,000 steals so
go grab them because these are
definitely worth to steal although also
the DLC character executions you solve
for centering in shinobi they're not
offer councils justice because they are
come with patch 1.09 and 1.09 is going
to be releasing today for PC in the next
week for council so don't worry guys but
we're still getting them next week so
just have to hold off and if you don't
remember what is in patch 1.09 I'll link
you a video in the description view you
get caught up with that next up if you
have you played any time this week you
might have noticed Ubisoft servers got
[ __ ] up [ __ ] up again so we're
getting more champion status to
compensate for it I honestly have lost
count the amount of times the servers
have went down and they how many days of
champion status we've received because
this is honestly no point even buying
champion status even more next up
congratulations to the samurai for the
run for victory meaning that's a tie
game between the Knights and Samurai two
to two but the Vikings can still tie it
and then who knows what will happen when
we tie it honestly I don't really care
too much about the faction war but some
of you do so that's why I like to report
on it the next couple dev streams are
going to be jam-packed with info
according to Eric Pope such as new
characters and the new character info
more public test dates and possible
public tests coming to Council because
at the beginning of season 3 so be sure
to stay tuned here so I give you all the
information on the new patches I got you
all covered a new event is here and it's
called the duel so go participate in
duel to get your 2000 steal next up was
a Q&A with Damian because Roman was out
for the week so to basically summarize
there's going to be a possibility of
team shuffling after matches coming to
an end in the near future they are like
I said before looking to make more
public-house hopefully coming next month
this would really help finding bugs and
patches and pagin them before they do
release in the game there's also a small
possibility of this happening but when
after a match ends more than half the
players leave the session normally ends
and kicks you out but there they came up
with a system hopefully that will be
implemented so that instead of you
getting booted out of the
session you'll be recued into a match
automatically with the player still left
in it so that will probably be very
useful Ubisoft is also experimenting
with a system to have all the unequipped
gear be turned into Salvage by the touch
of one button and not going in and
selecting them one by one
I personally are 100% done with this
because I waste so much time dismantling
gear that I don't need and this would
really help a lot but that's going to be
the end of the video guys sorry it was
short but the devs did say there wasn't
much today like I said except those
executions which is probably the main
reason you came here judge though they
are pretty [ __ ] beast I hope you all
did enjoy the video if you did leave a
like dislike it if you didn't subscribe
if you're new and then hit that Bell
right next to it to be part of the
notification squad only takes a couple
seconds it really does help me out
though so you never do miss a video of
mine and good bye guys I'll see you in
the next upload